bon les chéri j'ai découvert une vidéo
une jeune fille ce film pendant qu'elle
est au travail et je pense bien je n'ai
pas fait de quoi une fille cachée
ah non maintenant qu'ils voient plus
dans ton plus dur est odorat ou qu'on va
regarder
après toujours du bien à elle qui est
une fête donc vous dites la vérité vous
et isabelle alors là par malheur elle
est un truc moi j'ai faim tout faire à
chaque fois vous la voyez pas parce que
correa par la caméra sur l ennemi c wad
ici comme ça dans l'oreille mon frère et
elle va chercher mais je sais pas ce
qu'il ya sur ma vie il ya le collier
d'immunité
elle sort des trucs là mais sans
déconner laddh à la fois à la fortune
mis en terre à la sortie son oreille à
miel pops ravi dans le lit direct on la
mange et c'est les crayons je mets
souvent dans les oreilles
non là vous mettez vos doigts vous
mettez pas vos doigts dans les oreilles
des signes de temps en temps le sais pas
ce que j'aurais elle va bien avec la
force de porter des casques non ce que
je fais le plus souvent c'est manger
avec mes doigts bernard 7 curer les
oreilles bah ouais en fait ça fait jouer
vous savez que ça fait jouir de mettre
le stylo dans l'oreille ah oui ça aurait
jouir d'un stylo comptable à mon avis ce
qui est sorti
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bien fait don de vous à moi c'est les
salles à regarder away a dès que je peux
me débarrasser d'une crotte de nez je le
fous sur maman dit m non mais c'est vrai
que je le fais je le fais avec rod et
dewey c'est souvent par se tiennent bien
sûr le dois aussi donc parce qu'une
crainte de n'être pas dans le court on a
raison ça veut dire moi moi je me
rappelle à l'école je vous dirais bon il
faut pas le faire c'est relou françois
je faisais comme ça je me mettais
commence et je regarde j'ai appelé des
mecs ça fait très très voilà c'est grave
très bien même aujourd'hui comme ça des
crottes de free iliad mais parfois ça
reste collé donc c'est difficile et
bethioua spécialiste des crottes de
zenga n'est ce pas toi qu'est-ce que
vous faites don de vos jean michel mr
dois je faire par l'ensemble de votre
carrière
[Applaudissements]
il apprend de la bouche c'est par mesure
écologie alors il paraît que tout le
monde le fait ouais ouais y'a plein de
produits de beauté dans ma douche
donc je ne peux pas ouais je suis un fan
de produits de beauté vous à l'étagé
produit par don intéressante chez avec
un but et des produits de beauté ou
flessel mes impôts mais je mets beaucoup
de crème des crèmes pour le corps soit
la semaine pour la visa le q q ha ouais
ouais ouais j'suis du talk sur le cube
comme des bébés dans la capitale le look
est passé j'avais d'après j'avais la
farine sur la porte de gand mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui font
pipi sous la douche vraiment que tu fais
de honteux dont moi c'est comme la fille
en fait je lâche ghd paix tant vincent g
jour dans le cas nous mêmes et non pas
dans lequel lorsque banque allemande va
j'y suis tout seul mais plus quand je
fais que des potes quand on est 3 400
voitures 1 qui voit les fenêtres fermées
je lâche mes parents arrivés bien
entendu ce vieil adage premier son
propre répéteurs ouais ouais pas chez
vous gardez toujours ça me fait toujours
ça ma mosquée dans les yeux quand papa
tu finis quand ya pas de filles c'est
mieux c'est l'avant c'est la poule qui
caquettent capendu le sac ouvert et vous
pour ça j'étais coupé raymond pardon non
non non non pas du tout les stations
françaises comme un truc intéressant à
dire non ça viendra pas cette année
on a tous une épidémie on a des trucs
non non c'est bon alors oui que sophie
koch moi je fais des trucs affreux tout
le temps j'ai des petites statuettes
avec mes crottes de nez aux légumes à
tous ces statuettes avec vos crottes de
nez tellement koh lanta et après je les
jette et plus elles font nous et puis je
suis content non satisfaction mais ça ne
marche pas chez elle à flinguer à la
flatteur 5 à 10 m et 100 m à sortir
demain c'est là bas qu'il fait des
statuettes avec ses crottes de zen c'est
sûr mais c'est vrai javou et puis non je
fais d'autres trucs je fais pipi ou sur
les piscines
wifeo aaa à la piscine je dois vous
souhaite il peut dans les piscines et
spas dans les boutiques de la com ça
qu'on est là le fait du plongeoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons nous adresser pas ça quand
vous étiez petits cantons que si vous
faisiez j'ai testé pour vous c'est non
barré mais chez toi je suis sûr que j'ai
fait des fautes que c'est bon et moi
j'ai mes orteils je peux faire ça avec
et j'attrape tout ah ouais ouais c'est
d'ailleurs attrapé un livre alors
organisé le 7
ça va la pression est un peu plus
rigoler je rigole pas avec vos oreilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi je quand je fais la vaisselle
nu parce que chez soi c'est déjà très
centré autour
non j'adore faire gicler le produit sur
mon corps ça c'est mon kiff quand je
suis tout seul enfin tout n'est pas là
car je fais gic et je vous donne pas la
marque message x est bon ben ouais je
vous le redis emploi l'asile
lorsque vous si on est en quarantaine
faut aller directement là bas a glissé
sous les directs hier il nous dit qu'il
passait me souviens à enlever la
poussière là il nous dit je fais la
vaisselle lui et je me mets du produit
sur le corps en fait j'adore faire la
vaisselle nu s'est moqué ça toujours été
mais est-ce que sans lui je vais vous
dire il avait deux émissions choix si
oui les talents tpe ou terminés dans
crime c'est sûr et c'est sur c'est sûr
et certain
j'ai loué un petit peu un merci on a eu
tout le monde je m'habille et déjà du
classement